when I started Microsoft I didn't think
of it as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing it's
Troy could have gone bankrupt but you
know I had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to the thing that was scary to me
wasn't quitting and starting the company
it was when I started hiring my friends
and they expected to be paid and then we
had customers who went bankrupt
customers that I counted on and so then
I got this incredibly conservative
approach that I wanted to have enough
money in the bank to pay a Year's worth
of payroll I'm almost true to that the
whole time we have about 10 billion now
which is is pretty much enough for the
next year he consistently ranks in the
Forbes list of the world's wealthiest
people he's one of the best known
entrepreneurs of the personal computer
Revolution he's the second most generous
philanthropist in America having given
over 28 billion dollars to charity he's
Bill Gates and here his top 10 rules for
success
if you're going to start a company it
takes so much energy that you know you
it better overcome your your feeling of
risk I don't think that you necessarily
if you're going to start a company
should do it at the start of your career
I think there's a lot to be said for
working for a company learning how they
do things you know if you're young it's
hard to go lease premises they they made
that hard for me you couldn't rent a car
uh when you were uh under 25 at the time
so I was always taking taxis to go see
customers
the people would you know people say
we're going to go have a discussion in
the bar well I couldn't go to the bar
[Applause]
and
but you know that's fun because I'll
tell you when people are first skeptical
and angle this kid doesn't know anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product and you know
something they actually tend to go
overboard and they think whoa you know
they know a lot uh let's really do an
incredible amount with these people so
our youth at least in this country was a
huge asset for us once we reached a
certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people
um because they'll be a little bit
conservative about whether they should
come in and take the risk and it took
three or four years before we could go
out into the normal sort of employment
pool but those those problems that come
with starting to firm you better think
of those as as part of the the pleasure
part of the the challenge that that is
part of the the excitement
I want to thank Harvard for this honor
I'll be changing my job next year and it
will be nice to finally have a college
degree on my resume
I applaud the graduates for taking a
much more direct route to your degrees
from our my part I'm just happy that the
Crimson called me Harvard's most
successful Dropout
I guess that makes me valedictorian of
my own special class
I did the best of everyone who failed
[Laughter]
but I also want to be recognized as the
guy who got Steve Ballmer to drop out of
business school
thank you
I'm a bad influence
that's why I was invited to speak at
your graduation
if I'd spoken at your orientation
fewer of you might be here today
[Applause]
I'm in meetings a lot my calendar gets
very full with those and then at night
after the kids have gone to bed I'm on
email a great deal I get get messages
during the day that's my chance to give
long responses and then over the weekend
I I send a lot of mail as well as well I
take two weeks a year to just go off and
read and think where I'm not interrupted
by work or anything else I'm just
solidly trying to think about the future
and people get to send me things to read
as part of that so-called think week so
it's a nice mix of things about 25
percent of the time that I'm out uh
traveling around meeting with customers
Europe Asia and that sort of helps me
think okay do we have the right
priorities what what are people
responding well to and what would they
they like to see us do better
hello
I'm Bill Gates chairman of Microsoft
in this video you're going to see the
future
windows
Microsoft first came up with the windows
concept back in 1983
and today the leading software users
have switched into the windows
environment
it's really incredible how quickly our
powerful applications like Word and
Excel and PowerPoint have been adopted
it's not just Microsoft applications
even companies like word perfect and
Lotus have now come out with Windows
applications and every week we see new
Innovative work
it's really attracting all the
innovation in the industry
we predicted this a long time ago
and now it's the future the key point
there is you've got to enjoy what you do
every day and for me that's working with
very smart people it's working on new
problems you know every time we think
hey we've had a little bit of success
we're pretty careful not to dwell on it
too much because the bar gets raised I
love Bridge uh Bridge helps you think
it's a game you can play your entire
life and keep getting better and better
I think anybody who's good at Bridge is
going to be great at a lot of things so
I really encourage people to get
involved and I want to thank the people
who've put things together for juniors
they'll be thanking you the rest of
their life because bridge is such a
great sport
I talked to my dad I talked to Warren I
had talked to my wife Melinda so I have
enough people that know me and actually
know where my uh judgment isn't its
strongest where I might get over excited
about something or you know forget to
think about something and so they're
good at correcting particularly Melinda
good at correcting uh whatever uh those
blind spots are and I think it's good to
encourage your friends and advisors uh
to really give them that license you
know I can go to a party and forget to
say hello to various people or something
that's a very minor example of my blind
spots not to the hostess
Melinda would help me do that yeah
so you know a small number of people
that you can turn to on on certain key
things is a great great asset my best
business decisions really have to do
with uh
picking people you know deciding to go
into partnership with Paul Allen uh is
is probably at the top of the list and
then subsequently uh hiring a friend
Steve Ballmer
and having somebody who you totally
trust who's totally committed who shares
your vision and yet he has a little bit
different set of skills and also acts as
a check on you you know some of the
ideas you come up with you run by them
because you know they're going to say
hey wait a minute uh you know have you
thought about this and that and just you
know the the benefit of sparking off of
somebody who's who's got that kind of
Brilliance it's not only made it fun but
it's really led to a lot of success so
picking picking a Partners is crucial I
had one habit that uh I developed when I
when I was at college that was actually
a very bad habit which was I like to
show people that I didn't do any work uh
and that I didn't go to classes and I
didn't care and then at the very last
minute uh like two days before the test
I'd get serious about it and and people
people thought that was funny uh you
know that was my positioning the guy who
did not nothing until the last minute
then when I went into business that was
a really bad habit and it took me a
couple years to get over that nobody
praised me because I I would do things
at the last minute and I tried to
reverse uh to students I'd actually uh I
didn't think that highly of who were
always organized and had things done on
time I'm still working on it but uh
procrastination is not a good good habit
bill can change clothes in the car so
I'm gonna challenge Bill Gates my
partner at Facebook Cheryl Sandberg and
Netflix's founder and CEO Reed Hastings
I'm glad to give to ALS it's a great
cause but I I want to accept this
challenge I want to do it better than
it's been done
been working on this you know got this
design
there we go yeah
it's gonna be great
[Music]
I'm here
to join the people bringing attention to
Lou Gehrig's Disease by taking the ALS
Ice Bucket Challenge
I'm gonna Challenge three more people
Elon Musk Ryan Seacrest and Chris
Anderson of Ted consider yourself
challenged you have 24 hours
good luck
[Applause]
people
[Music]
let me tell you about my best friend is
so much
[Music]
[Applause]
is it true that you can leap over a
chair from a standing position
depends on the size of the chair but
I'll cheat a little bit
yes
[Music]
by the way I believe in winners and
losers and especially the freedom to
fail me
[Music]
da da
dude hey
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Warren Buffett
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there tap dancing to
Work Warren how can other people tap
dance to work what's the secret of that
you find your passion you find your
passion I was very very lucky to find
out you know when I was uh
seven or eight years old and